J'ai manqué mon professeur mes amis tous mes
camarades de classe ils me manquent
[Musique]
maintenant quand elle a fini son école primaire
donc je ne pouvais pas me permettre
pour le début donc pour le moment je
lui ai demandé d'étudier je suis inquiet que je
ne le sois pas  aller à l'école mais même mon
camarade de classe ils me demandent pourquoi je ne
vais pas à l'école
[Musique]
merci
étranger
[Musique]
9 août. et je suis né en août
c'est vers le 8 2008.
Je suis  22 000 nuits d'août
et ma maman me met sur cette plage
pour que cette femme que j'avais l'habitude de dire mes enfants
à côté de vous alors elle a maintenant dit que c'est elle
qui m'a porté jusqu'à notre maison
qu'elle ne s'occupe pas de moi mais alors
quand je '  J'ai neuf huit ans,
c'est parfois moi J'avais l'habitude de battre sa
fille parfois
Parfois, certaines personnes me donnaient de
la nourriture à l'extérieur qui sentait c'est qu'elle
ne savait pas comme ça que
si quelque chose arrive,
je serai sûr et quelqu'un se battra si
tout ce qui leur est arrivé, elle
va me pousser loin de chez moi donc
c'est le lendemain que
notre fille est morte qu'elle a dit que c'est
cette femme qui soigne le médecin
[Musique]
nous voyons des enfants qui se remettent juste de la
toxicomanie dans certains cas vous  voir
des gens qui traversent une dépression, des
personnes suicidaires qui s'automutilent
qui essaient d'y mettre fin et tout
cela et des personnes qui ont subi
des abus ainsi que différents types d'
abus physiques sexuels, donc notre travail consiste généralement à
leur donner d'abord  l'environnement dans lequel
ils se sentent aimés, nous pensons que c'est là que le
travail le plus important est fait
un
[Musique] dont
vous avez besoin pour être satisfait [
Musique]
est l'occasion pour moi d'apprendre et
de grandir afin que je puisse changer le monde et que je
puisse être un brillant  une personne dans la vie et une
meilleure personne dans la vie
[Musique]
étranger
d'où tu peux aller à l'école un endroit où
tu peux retourner quand l'école a
fermé c'est un problème beaucoup de gens ne
vont pas à l'école pour des raisons de sécurité
aussi  c'est juste comme hé mon fils reste à côté
de moi nous ne savons pas où nous allons
être la nuit ou demain matin c'est
vraiment difficile de dire oh construisons plus
d'écoles, ayons plus d'enseignants et
ensuite rendons obligatoire pour chaque
enfant de  aller à l'école que l'école ne
fonctionnera pas pour tous les enfants parce qu'il
y a d'autres problèmes socio-économiques
qui rendront l'éducation impossible
[Musique]
merci